et pour en parler nous sommes avec
michel parigot chercheur au cnrs
président du collectif corona victime
bonsoir michel parigot merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés jean bernard gervais
journaliste spécialiste santé et
spécialistes social merci jean verdun
gervais également d'être avec nous alors
je vais me tourner tout d'abord vers le
chercheur de au cnrs pour commencer que
dit la recherche française malade depuis
des années quel est votre sentiment sur
le terrain qu'est ce que vous constatez
est ce qu'on constate enfin si si on
regarde pour pour le pour le coc vite
c'est que deux façon générale la
recherche est au rendez vous enfin si
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire et on
était capable à la recherche a été
capable de développer très rapidement
quand même des vaccins et maintenant ddd
des traitements donc la recherche
elle-même est au rendez vous c'est
beaucoup plus la question de l'interface
entre les états et la recherche qui est
un problème et qui est particulièrement
un problème en france et qui est un qui
ne qui ne concerne pas du tout que le
coc vide qui concerne le financement de
la recherche et l'orientation delà de la
recherche en général les transformations
qui ont été faites dans l'est dans les
dernières années qui effectivement va
vers beaucoup plus vert l'immédiat que
vers la recherche fondamentale
or tous les traitements qui se
construisent et les vaccins notamment
avec la eran message et c'est quelque
chose qui reposent sur des recherches de
long terme c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
fait immédiatement on le fait on peut le
faire immédiatement parce que derrière
il ya beaucoup de recherche qui ce qui
se fait de recherche fondamentale et
c'est à ce niveau là que enfin c'est un
des niveaux où on a un problème en
france
la lenteur donc le long terme
jean bernard gervais
justement le bonnet d'âne dans la course
à la vaccination c'est l'illustration
devient ce que viens de décrire michel
parigot
oui non c'est très intéressant ce que
vient de nous décrire michel parigot
puisqu'on l'a vu terrain au niveau en
fait des chiffres et des scandales en
matière de recherche que je voulais
rappeler c'est tout simplement en fait
l'actualité en fait de sanofi
actuellement qui a dégagé des bénéfices
record et qui parallèlement alors ça ne
concerne pas en fait le col vite ça
concerne plutôt les activités en cardio
vasculaires je crois va remettre en
cause 368 3 164 emplois dans la
recherche et le développement voilà
d'une part on peut aussi citer on a
parlé tout à l'heure de l'institut
pasteur de lille de l'institut pasteur
on peut citer aussi l'institut pasteur
de lille qui va faire financer là pour
le coup en fait un traitement
expérimental kobe 19 grâce à élever
marche et non pas grâce à l'état
français
donc on se rend bien compte là pour le
coup que l'état français est totalement
l'art la ramasse malgré en fait la
performance des équipes de recherches
sur le terrain et laurent le nerf de la
guerre c'est évidemment la finance vous
propose provient qu'on comprenne
comparaison n'est pas raison bien
évidemment mais on a regardé combien les
états remettait sur la table parce que
c'est important en gros quel part de
leur produit intérieur brut il réservé
pour la recherche
regardez tout d'abord pour l'europe 1
c'est l'allemagne qui met le plus
d'argent sur la table
123 milliards de dollars +2 3% du pib
allemand quand la france elle pousse
péniblement à 2,2 pour cent de son pib
pour 61 milliards de dollars devant donc
le royaume uni et regardez maintenant
dans le monde qui sont les pays qui
investissent le plus dans la recherche
et bien c'est israël on les retrouve qui
consacre près de 5% de sa richesse
nationale à la recherche
ensuite la corée du sud et le japon les
français doivent mettre les bouchées
doubles s'ils n'ont cesser la fuite des
cerveaux
michel parigot oui mais il ya d'abord si
on revient sûr sûr sûr sanofi ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que on a un mécanisme de
financement de la recherche privée
qui est un qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
vraiment incitatif c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est un financement qui est
automatique confortable indépendamment
de ce qu'ont fait et qui donc favorise
il serait bon je vais pas voir l'eau
gazeuse vous demander votre salaire on
dirait qu'à la télévision l'a enfin tout
de même avec des salaires très bas pour
vous les chercheurs français c'est le c1
un autre problème c'est effectivement le
problème la question des salaires des
chercheurs un chercheur débutant ou un
universitaire débutant ses 1800 euros
nets
c'est pas compétitifs même avec les pays
voisins
même avec l'allemagne ou l'angleterre
pour ne pas parler des états unis donc
effectivement on est un chercheur
débutant c'est quelqu'un qui a l'âge
quand même d'un sportif finissant donc
c'est aussi ça parce que c'est un
investissement de long terme se lancer
dans la rade ans dans la recherche
donc effectivement il ya un problème un
problème très claire de salaire qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas attractif mais
ça n'explique pas complètement pour le
pour le pour le privé le privé pourrait
fonctionner différemment simplement là
on a tendance à financer des grosses
structures plutôt qu'à financer les des
entreprises réactive dans ce cas là on
voit bien qu'on compare y est beaucoup
plus sur sanofi que sur des petites
start up sur des biotech qui ont besoin
elles de financement parce qu'elles ont
pas l ont pas le de financement propres
ailes commencer le débuté donc il
faudrait il faudrait impulser et
impulser très vite dans une situation
comme celle là jean michel jarre pardon
jean bernard gervais
elle est la pardonnez moi là la solution
justement insuffler peut-être plus
d'argent sur les biotech est petit et
pas forcément sur les gros groupes
s'étaient pourtant un petit peu le
postulat de départ de du président macro
un set de stop start up nation
oui tout à fait il ya apparemment c'est
une promesse qui n'a pas été tenue
sans polémiquer une promesse de plus
mais oui je voulais revenir en fait sur
les grandes masses que vous avez annoncé
tout à l'heure 60 milliards en fait
d'euros qui était financé qui finançait
la recherche en france
je pense qu'il s'agissait en fait de la
totalité la recherche la recherche
médicale et le financement de la
recherche médicale est bien plus
modestes un par exemple en fait pour ne
citer que le programme hospitalier de
recherche clinique
on est plutôt autour des 150 millions
d'euros le budget de l'un sert par
exemple c'est autour des 800 millions
d'euros quand le budget par exemple la
recherche médicale
le mih américain est au tour des 33
entre 33 et 40 milliards d'euros d'euros
enfin 40 milliards de dollars et 33
milliards de d'euros envoyés en fait on
est loin en fait des 60 milliards
annoncés on est plutôt là pour le coup
en terme de recherche médicale autour
des 2 3 milliards de recherches
médicales et une dégringolade en fait la
france en termes de publications
également puisque la france est
actuellement en recherche médicale au
huitième rang ce qui n'était pas le cas
hier donc en quelques années elle était
aux cinquième sixième rang à ces faits
passés devant par les pays-bas par la
chine également
voilà donc un lieu parallèlement fait au
dégraissage et aux plans sociaux de
sanofi il faut aussi dire aussi que le
scandale c'est aussi la revente en fait
de biotech c'est-à-dire de petites
perles petit de technologie qui avait
été acheté par sanofi et qui sont
revendus actuellement donc on s'aperçoit
en fait que pour satisfaire finalement
des intérêts et des objectifs financiers
non seulement en fait en des graisses en
interne en se débarrassant fait des
chercheurs qui sont les salariés par
sanofi mais on fait débarrasse aussi en
fait des perles en technologie en
biotechnologiques ont été rachetés
récemment donc le scandale et les
doubles en ce qui concerne américain
sanofi la recherche privée petit point
en fait que je voulais ajouter où vous
aviez cité en fait emmanuel macron
concernant cette volonté en fait de
relancer la recherche c'était une
volonté qui avait été aussi
taj et par monsieur sarkozy à l'époque à
puisque c'est lui qui avait en 2010
lancé les instituts hospitalo
universitaires qui était sensé qui était
censé pas relancer et regagné en fait
d'aider place de la france en termes de
recherche médicale ça n'a pas été le cas
mais toujours est il qu'il ya eu quand
même malgré tout en fait une percée
facilité en fait le principal il ya
chute qui a fait parler de lui ces
derniers temps il y en a six en france
mais il ya quand même eu une volonté
aussi de réorganiser la recherche
toujours pareils en fait en santé est
une espèce de bellefeuille qui fait que
les financements en fait s'éparpille à
droite et à gauche entre la recherche
fondamentale et la recherche clinique
d'autre part la complexité aussi à
retrouver en fait ces petits dans la
totalités entre l'ain serbe sait mais
reste les issues du programme
hospitalier de recherche clinique dans
les centres hospitaliers universitaires
voilà un véritable mille feuilles qui
complexifie encore la possibilité pour
les chercheurs en fait de trouver les
financements pour illustrer un ce que ce
que vous nous dites sur les financements
fin novembre 2020 les députés ont adopté
la loi de programmation et de la
recherche 25 milliards d'euros étalé sur
dix ans les scientifiques français ont
dénoncé d'ailleurs un sous financement
regarder cette tribune de 4600
chercheurs paru dans le journal le monde
les conditions sont indignes de la
réforme dont nous avons besoin ce qu'il
faut un grand plan de financement
pourraient former des talents dans les
écoles d'excellence michel parigot vous
auriez pu vous fait d'ailleurs peut-être
partie de ces chercheurs qui sont en
colère il faut justement un plan de
financement pour réformer les grandes
écoles alors les les grandes écoles cdu
c'est du long terme
parce qu'on ne peut pas enfin il
faudrait évidemment résoudre le problème
des grandes écoles la coupure entre les
grandes écoles
ça dépend des domaines enfin après il
faut y aller plus plus plus précisément
mais la pure entre les grandes écoles et
les universités en france est un
problème majeur dans un certain nombre
de domaines où les meilleurs vont dans
des écoles où on n'essaie pas l'endroit
où on fait vraiment de l'aa delà de la
recherche et où on sort voilà donc c'est
c'est quelque chose de compliqué mais
qui peut pas se faire immédiatement
c'est quelque chose qu'il faudrait faire
sur le long terme et qu on a on n'a
jamais fait parce qu'on peut pas
supprimer instantanément les les grandes
écoles il faudrait arriver à refondre
tout ça mais ça ne sais pas ça ne s'est
pas vraiment fait dans l'est dans l'est
dans les réformes qui a qui a eu à
actuellement et le problème c'est que
les réformes vont plutôt dans un sens de
l'immédiateté que dans un sens de la
recherche de la recherche fondamentale
de financement récurrent des
laboratoires et donc c'est uniquement
des chaussures sur projet avec une
dimension de communication d'immédiates
haute et de mode
donc c'est tout ça qui ne qui ne qui ne
va pas avec en plus le fait qu' il ya de
moins en moins de deux postes de
chercheurs pérenne
c'est à dire on essaye de aussi la dalle
est dans la précarité
donc c'est sait et c'est pas compatible
avec ça peut être compatible avec un
certain nombre de choses ce n'est pas
avec la recherche fondamentale par
exemple merci en tout cas à tous les
deux on y voit plus clair sur voilà les
failles française dans le domaine de la
recherche merci michel parigot merci à
vous jean bernard gervais